>>Niklas: As people are willing
to buy more, they're making more
and they're charging more for it.
>>Erin: And how does that relate
back to our free market principles?
>>Niklas: As demand goes
up, supply goes up.
>>Kisa: Because we assess
student Mastery of Competencies,
we have a better understanding of
exactly what the student can do.
It's a more equitable system for
assessing student understanding.
And it also puts the ownership of
the learning into the kids hands.
>>Daniel: You're being assessed
on Competency Number 3,
Presentation of Learning.
>>Kisa: Competency-Based Learning
is the idea that students are trying
to meet certain big picture
understandings.
Not complete a bunch of tasks
and jump through a bunch of hoops
and average a bunch of scores out.
>>Erin: I want to make sure that you
guy are aware of the Competencies.
>>Danielle: The Competencies
are anywhere between five
to seven statements that say, "These
are the focus areas for this course."
This is what you need to
demonstrate that you know
to have mastered this course.
>>Kisa: The most fundamental shift
an individual teacher could make is
to just pick those traditional
categories you used to have
in your gradebook, Quizzes,
Tests, Homework,
and shift them to the
Enduring Skill Sets and Habits
of Mind for your discipline.
>>Student: We're going to
have like two of each--
>>Kisa: And the kids, because that's how
they're being assessed start to think
about things a little bit more in terms
of the Enduring Understandings
you're trying to get at.
>>Erin: Good morning!
I'd like you to start
working on your project today.
It goes with Competency 2.
It is over here on the walls.
>>Erin: I think the Competency-Based
approach is better,
because it gives students the ability
to demonstrate competence
in a variety of ways.
>>Niklas: In Economics class,
the Competency that we are demonstrating
is Supply and Demand Systems.
>>Niklas: So they charge 100, 200,
300, up to 600 dollars for it,
because it's fairly cheap to make them.
>>Niklas: We have individual
freedom when it comes
to the work that we can do.
>>Kaylee: We can do a test,
or we could do a project.
Either like a PowerPoint or a poster.
>>Erin: So you're still
set on this SpongeBob idea?
>>Student: Yes.
>>Erin: I have two students
who have been hounding me
about a SpongeBob episode.
>>Student: He has to buy the
chocolate bars, and has to buy bags
to carry the chocolate bars.
>>Erin: Is that part of the episode?
Okay.
>>Darin: The whole episode really talks
about how there's different
ways of selling things.
There's different styles
of how you sell them.
>>Erin: So your product
that you're going
to focus on are the chocolate bars.
>>Erin: They believe that selling
chocolate bars demonstrates the concepts
of Demand and Supply very well.
>>Student: Consumer tastes and
preferences, definitely demonstrated.
>>Erin: Right.
>>Erin: So I challenged them
to create a series of graphs,
and then analyze each graph
and look at that interplay
of Demand and Supply and the prices.
>>Erin: What could you look at?
>>Kaylee: The preferences.
>>Erin: Okay.
>>Kaylee: And then like
the number of sellers.
>>Kaylee: I'm not a very
good test-taker,
but with the project we're able to
say, "This is what I need to do,
and this is what I need to work
on, rather than just trying
to cram it all into our minds.
>>Erin: So it sounds like
you've got two ideas,
but we need to come up with two more.
>>Kaylee: Okay.
>>Erin: Choice allows them the
opportunity to be cognizant
of their learning style,
and how they learn best.
>>Erin: We'll continue
with this tomorrow.
Have a good day!
>>Daniel: Ladies and gentleman, when
you start to think of your procedure
from the lab, remember
you are in charge today.
>>Julianna: Since this is
completely our decision how we do it,
we have to write our materials,
procedures, all that stuff that we did.
>>Daniel: The whole idea of
Competency-Based, it puts ownership
in the students' hands, to demonstrate
that they were able to master
that particular competency.
>>Daniel: As close as you can.
>>Daniel: You can have one
area of the room on something
that other students have
already finished.
>>Student: See this right here.
>>Daniel: Sometimes you'll have
in a different corner students
going back to revisit something.
>>Student: Which one's this?
Sugar.
>>Student: Sugar.
And then this is NACL.
>>Kisa: They have to
meet each Competency.
>>Student: Procedure 1 was get--
>>Student: Get the chunks of candy.
>>Kisa: So they could do a
really good job with the concept,
but not do a really good job
with their science process.
They don't redo that assignment,
but in the next lab that we do,
maybe that student does
a formal lab report.
>>Student: Here.
>>Kisa: Or they could take
a written test instead.
They could do an essay on something.
And you don't just move on with
a big gap in your understanding.
We don't let you do that!
>>Student: Drop, drop.
>>Kisa: Because you're assessing the
student in a way that fits the student--
>>Daniel: Excellent, good job.
>>Kisa: You're getting a better
assessment of where the kid really is.
>>Student: You have your price,
and then you have like the supply.
>>Kisa: Competency-Based
education is just, in general,
much more fair for every student.
>>Julianna: Ready?
Go!